hi there today we're looking at the
lottery ticket hypothesis finding sparse
trainable neural networks by Jonathan
Franco and Michael carbon so this paper
is sort of an empirical paper into what
makes neural networks train successfully
and it comes out of the literature of
pruning so they say neural network
pruning techniques right they have been
around for a while they can reduce the
parameter counts of trained networks by
over 90% decreasing storage requirements
and improving computational performance
or inference without compromising
accuracy right so what does this mean if
you have a neural network let's say you
just have three nodes each layer you
have to layer here you have a neural
network here if you have a fully
connected neural network every nodes
going to be connected with every node in
the next layer right and these are these
connections are your weights your Thetas
and you're going to train them which
means you have a you have a number of
steps in this direction and let's say
you have you have a test set accuracy
right here so here are steps you're
going to train them and if you train
them your accuracy will reach a certain
point right I'm just gonna draw the end
point here let's say you reach a 90%
test accuracy so your network
generalizes pretty well that's pretty
good so people have been wondering this
these networks they they require quite a
lot of storage you know this is nine
connections right here so three times
three and this is also nine connections
can we make it smaller but still retain
the accuracy and this is where pruning
comes in so with pruning people would go
and after you train them so the first
step is train
the full Network right and then the
second step is prune now when put when
you prune you basically select among the
weights that you have that you have
trained you select the best ones in in
some form or another in this case people
just select the ones with the largest
magnitudes but there are multiple
techniques to do this and this is very
related to things like quantization or
distillation so with pruning you just
leave away some of the weights or most
of the weights and you hope that you
still retain a pretty good accuracy
right here right um sorry actually we
don't need these steps thing so you
leave away weights and you retain a good
accuracy so pruning methods have been
deployed successfully to make networks
use less space or be faster to evaluate
because of course with less numbers you
need to do less calculations so this
paper builds on top of this and it
basically says all right if if we do the
following if if we now take this network
that we identified after training and we
um we just take this network and we
train it from the beginning only this
sub Network right so three is retrain
then it will also perform pretty well or
even better under one condition right so
if you only train this thing it will
perform well under one condition
and the condition is that you transfer
over the initial weights so right the
question is can we train just the small
network from the beginning so that we
don't have to train the big network
right and the paper identifies that this
works
if your initial weights theta0 of the
small network are equal to the initial
weights of the large network right just
so just the ones where you pour them
over but basically the short answer is
no and the reason is if you only want to
train this small Network you need to
know the good initialization of these of
these weights all here and the good
initialization you only know after
you've trained the large network and
actually identified which of these
connections make sense so you can't just
take a smaller network from the
beginning you have to train the larger
one then you know which weights and
which initializations make sense so this
is the winning lottery ticket hypothesis
basically it states and we can read it
out in full the lottery ticket
hypothesis is a randomly initialized
dense neural network contains a sub
network that is initialized such that
when trained in isolation it can match
the test accuracy of the original
network after training for at most the
same number of iterations right now the
important part here is that it contains
a sub Network right that is initialized
such that when trained in isolation so
two things are important it is important
the structure of the network of the sub
Network but it is also important what
are the initialization of the
connections now so the paper kind of
hints at why neural networks work at all
and the reason why neural networks work
is because we've often thought of a
neural networks have so many parameters
how can they even generalize the reason
is the following if we have a neural
network we throw so many parameters at
it some of the parameters one subset of
the parameters namely the red ones here
are going to be in
initialized in such a way in such a
beneficial way that training will
perform will make the network perform
well right so it's initialization plus
SGD on that that sub Network right so it
is actually only a very small sub
network that is responsible for the
performance of the neural network but
but that sub network needs to be
initialized at the correct position and
by over parameterizing these neural
networks so much we actually give it
combinatoric lee many sub networks to
choose from where the initialization
could be well so so because of this
combinatoric s' it means that if we over
parameterize by some margin then there's
almost guaranteed to be a good sub
network in there that can then perform
well alright so I hope this makes sense
it is basically it is not a way it is
not a magic thing where you now we can
we now can train the smaller networks it
is it is an explanation of why the over
parameterization in neural networks
makes sense because by over
parameterizing we allow the neural
networks to combine it to exploit the
combinatorics to find a good
well initialized sub Network that will
perform well and the evidence for this
is exactly the fact that if we transfer
over the sub Network it by itself will
reach the same performance or actually
exceed the performance but only if we
initialize it at the same point as it
was initialized in the original network
so here is how these these sub networks
are identified we've already hinted at
that but here is how the the paper does
it so it says identify winning tickets
first randomly initialize a neural
network this is the full neural network
right then train the network for J
iterations
arriving at some parameters right these
are the trained parameters prune P
percent of the parameters right so of
these parameters prune some right and
this is for in order to know which ones
you prune you need to have first the
trained the full neural network right so
this is the the capture you need to
train the full neural network to know
which ones you must prune and thereby
you create a mask M right and then they
say reset the remaining parameters to
their value in theta zero actually you
don't need to say remaining you can just
say reset the parameters to their values
in theta zero now this is also important
this is the same theta zero as it was at
the beginning of the training right so
you need to actually set them back to
those exact values and thereby you
create the winning ticket now this okay
actually if you if you just want to end
up with the Train Network than you then
this this uh this remaining thing here
is important but if you then want to
retrain you can only you can set
everything back and only train the
masked version of the network right and
they they say this this will identify
these winning tickets and it will
actually work better if you don't do
this in what they call one-shot but if
you do this iterative pruning that means
it repeatedly trains prunes and resets
the network over n rounds each round
principal P to the one over n percent of
the weights that survived the previous
round now why might that be
it might be and this is this is I think
some valid hypothesis that I myself put
forth here it might be that if you prune
some of the weights right let's say you
prune this one and this one what you'll
do is you put the responsibility of
these weights on two other weights so
maybe on this one in this one so as we
said they prune by by looking at which
weights are large so let's say here we
have the weights of the layer and these
are the magnitudes of the of the weights
right so okay so you would prune let's
say you only want to keep two of those
around so you would prune this one and
this one because these are pretty small
right here's the magnitude and you would
also prune that one right if you just do
this one shot and then you would retrain
and maybe these weights would end up
somewhat different but if you do this in
multiple rounds right let's say you
first prune one of them you only prune
the smallest one right this one here and
then you retrain and then your weights
actually change and all of the
responsibility that this weight carried
before is now transferred on to this
right so your new your new weights look
like this and you prune another one like
this and again all the responsibilities
of this would in my hypothetical example
fall on this one right and now if you
prune the third one you would actually
proven this one because you realize all
this weight here in absence of these two
other weights is actually important so
you would prune this one as well right
so I think that is why this kind of
iterative pruning method might work a
bit better than the one-shot pruning
method that they say here so they do a
lot of empirical investigation and I
just want to highlight a very few of
them but so that you you get the gist
and then that the paper goes into a lot
of detail and a lot of different
architectures that you can check out
yourself all right so here we have a
plot sorry that that deals with percent
of weights remaining so as you go to the
right here
uh they draw up and more and more
weights and realize this is a log plot
right so if the dashed lines here are
random proving which means you just drop
out a certain number of weights and then
you retrain and you can see that the
dashed line here it it starts dropping
and just becomes worse as you as you
have less and less weights remaining
which is exactly what's expected right
you prune the network
you make it smaller you make it less
performant and the more weights you take
away the less performing it is but
interestingly enough right if you do
this pruning that they suggest and then
retrain with the correct initialization
not only do you retain the same level of
accuracy for very long you see here this
is 2.9 or 1.2 percent of weights
remaining but you actually go higher
right so you can see here when you have
16 percent of weights remaining you
there's actually a significant
difference between the full network and
the prune Network and that's only by
simply training this winning hypothesis
so this I find very very fascinating and
again this is not a magic bullet that
you can do from the beginning but it
does give a clue that if you could train
sorry if you could train these from the
beginning then then you might actually
end up at a better point so it does
actually give a practical application
also you see they train faster so the
blue line here is the full network over
the course of training sorry this should
be blue so here is training iterations
and this is test accuracy so you see the
full network does something like this
now if you prune to what 20 percent of
the weights actually train faster and
you go higher and even if you have seven
percent of the weights you go almost as
high
so this is very interesting only when
you go to like one point nine percent of
the weights does your performance
degrade again and eventually actually go
lower than the original Network so that
that is pretty pretty pretty cool I
think
now they do as I said they do a lot of
investigation and I think one of the one
of the main takeaways is that is not
only the structure of the winning
hypothesis so it's not only the
structure of the sub network that makes
it to be a winning hypothesis it is
actually the initialization here I want
to show one of these plots they have
lots of thoughts what you can see here
for example sorry this is from my own
annotations again this is percent of
weights remaining and this is test
accuracy at the final iteration and if
we initialize the sub Network at its
original position like this method
suggest you see we first increase the
accuracy and then decrease it after a
long time if we take the same sub
Network right but we randomly
reinitialize it then it drops much
faster and actually immediately drops so
it really is about not only the
structure of the sub Network but about
its initialization I think that is that
is the core of the hypothesis here he
very interesting related finding and
that I just want to mention I find to be
that they actually discover that the
weights so if you have a weight of the
so if you have two kinds of weight let's
actually go up to my original drawing
here if you have if you compare how fast
or how far do the weights travel in
optimization space right so you can you
can basically look at how far weights
travel during optimization so you take
the full neural network here and you
look at a parameter
that ends up being in the winning
hypothesis theta theta zero and it goes
to theta and which final and you also
look at parameters that don't end up in
the winning hypothesis let's call this
theta one to theta also final prime not
too good at labeling and you look at how
far they travel you'll find that the
weights that end up in the winning
hypothesis they during optimization they
travel much further in optimization
space than weights that are not in the
winning hypothesis right they just stay
around much more so it's not that the
the kind of good network is already
contained in initialization it's much
more than than the good Network lends
itself very favorably to be initialized
by SGD right because it it travels
further
I mean adds GG has a bigger bigger pole
on it right I think there is a lot of
things that are yet to be explored
in this space and I think this paper is
a very cool contribution to our
understanding of how neural networks
work alright I invite you to check out
all the experiments they do a very
thorough job and with that I say bye-bye